hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a problem from today's leak
code contest to merge
triplets to form target triplet and this
problem is actually a little bit easier
than you might think so you can read the
description
basically we have a target triplet and
we're given a list of triplets and we
want to know if we can transform
this list of triplets into the target
triplet and we're given a
a single operation that we're allowed to
do we can take
any two triplets such as these two
triplets right
and we can set one of them equal to the
max of both of the triplets combined so
basically for
the first value we would take the
maximum in this case it's two
for the second value we would take the
maximum in this case it's seven
and for the third value we take the
maximum in this case it's five so we
would get
when we combine the two triplets we'd
get something like two seven
five and we wanna know if we're allowed
to do this kind of operation on
any of the triplets inside of our
triplets list as many times as we want
are we able to somehow get the target
triplet now your first idea might be
backtracking or
you know some other kind of complicated
high complexity solution but let me just
tell you there's a single
key observation that you can make that
will make this problem
super easy so let's try to figure that
out so remember that
this is our target triplet that we're
trying to make and we can take
any two triplets and then get the
maximum of those so
clearly our goal is to take smaller
values like maybe we have a one and
somehow get it to a two
which is the target for here and maybe
we have a six somewhere
and then take that and get it to be a 7.
but what happens if we have a value
that's
greater than the target see this triplet
8 4. now 1 is smaller than the value
we're looking for
4 is smaller than the value we're
looking for but what about 8
8 is bigger than the value we're looking
for so
what happens with this triplet if we
ever
try to combine this triplet with any
other
triplet we're always gonna get a value
that's either eight or maybe even bigger
than a if you know that other triplet
somehow had a nine in the middle or
something like that right
but we're always with this triplet we're
always going to get a value that's
greater than the target
7 that we're looking for so any triplet
any triplet in our list
at all that has a value in any position
that's greater than the corresponding
target value that we're looking for
is going to be useless for us so a
triplet like
this we're not even going to consider it
we're not even going to
look at it so from our input list of
triplets if we do
remove all triplets or like that that
have values that are too
great then we're going to be left with
triplets in our input that are either
equal to the target or less than the
target right they have values that are
equal or
less than the target so then at that
point once we're left with those
triplets
how do we know if maybe those triplets
can form the target
well we're not actually going to have to
go through and do these maximum
operations it's actually even easier
than that all we're going to do
is go through every single triplet and
see
does it have for every target value do
we have a
2 in the first position among any of the
triplets
do we have a 7 in the target value among
any of the triplets and do we have a 5
in
the third position among any of our
triplets
if we do then we can guarantee that
somehow some way that we can take these
triplets
you know combine them together and form
this because we know for sure
at every position in these remaining
triplets
the value is either exactly equal to the
target or less than the target so we
know for sure if we combine
all of them together we're not going to
go over the target
and we're definitely going to reach the
target if we have
all of those values we're looking for so
with that being said
the code is going to be pretty simple
all we're going to do is go through our
list of triplets
filter out the triplets that have a
value that's greater than
any value in the target and then we're
going to check among any of our triplets
can we
reach each of these target values if we
can basically if we if we can reach
all three of these values in our input
list of triplets
then we're going to return true
otherwise we return false
so basically this is going to be an o of
n time solution where we iterate through
every single triplet and go through
every single value in every single
triplet
so i'm going to initially make a set
called good
because basically just which positions
of the target are good like which ones
can we actually
complete so to this i'm going to be
adding the indices i'm going to be
either adding index 0
1 or 2. you know depending on which ones
we are able to complete and if the
length of this is
3 then we're going to return true if
it's 0 or less than 3
then we're going to return false so now
our brute force basically just going
through every single triplet
in the input list and if
we get a triplet so if this triplet at
position 0 has a value
that's greater than the target values uh
position zero or at position one if this
value is greater than the targets at
position one
and finally if at position two this
triplets value is greater than the
targets at position two
that means that this is one of those
triplets that we're going to filter out
so we can just continue on to the next
iteration of the loop
otherwise this triplet could contain
some of the target values we're looking
for so let's iterate through this
triplet and we are going to need the
index of this triplet the index in this
case is basically the position of each
value in the triplet so iv
in enumerate through this triplet
and so we're going to check if the value
at this position
i is equal to a value in the target
at position i so basically maybe the
zero value of this triplet matches the
zero value of the target then what we're
going to go ahead and do
is to our good set we're going to add
position i because that means we are
able to get position i from
some of our triplets and then we're
going to do the exact same thing for
every single triplet that is valid that
we're not going to be skipping
and then at the end if we know for sure
that the length
of good is equal to three then we're
going to return true
otherwise we're going to return false so
really we can just return
the result of this comparison so that's
the entire code you can see
that it does pass in this
leak code contest so i hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching